[Music]
one of the more challenging features to
build on a web application is a
drag-and-drop sortable list and it's
even more challenging if you need to
persist the data in a back-end database
instead of trying to reinvent the wheel
we're going to use a library called
draggable that's maintained by shop live
it's relatively lightweight and we can
wrap it in angular to make drag and drop
features much more enjoyable to code if
you're new the channel like and
subscribe and you can find the source
code on angular firebase comm what we're
building today is a sortable list of
emojis the user can add or remove items
from the list and they can drag items to
change the order and have that order be
saved in the database this is a pretty
complex thing to do from scratch because
if you notice when we drag an item it
creates a mirror of the original element
and toggles a whole bunch of CSS classes
on the container and the individual
items themselves draggable will make
this feature surprisingly easy but also
give us enough flexibility to build
something unique in addition firestore
recently released a couple of new helper
methods that make it easy to add or
remove elements from an array so we'll
take a look at those as well but the
first thing you need to get started is
an angular app with angular fire
installed from there we'll go to the
command line and install draggable with
NPM there are two main elements to this
demo first we have a smart component
which is our emoji component and it
handles retrieving items from the
database and can also add or remove new
emojis to the list then we have a
directive called sortable which I'm
going to call our dumb component because
a directive is essentially just a
component that doesn't have a custom
HTML template it can do pretty much
everything a component can do but
instead it attaches itself to a host
element and extends the functionality of
that element when working with sort of a
list like this you'll usually attach
this to an unordered list and then have
your list items be sortable within it
we'll start by building out the
directive and you'll notice that we're
importing a bunch of things here from
angular core and this is also where
we'll import sortable from Shopify
draggable we're going to implement the
after view and net lifecycle hook on
this directive just so we know that all
of the children elements are available
once we start running the sortable code
on it then we're going to have it emit a
custom event that has the new order of
the sorted item
in order to be able to do that we first
need to pass in the initial items which
we'll do with an input property on the
directive then after the items have been
sorted will emit our own custom event by
using the output decorator and an event
emitter there's quite a few different
events you can track here so I've
commented those out in case you need
them the only one we need is when the
actual sorting has been finished then
we'll inject element ref in the
constructor which will give us access to
the Dom element which in this case
should be an unordered list so once
that's done we can initialize sortable
by creating a new instance of the class
and then passing it the element ref
native element then it takes a second
argument with some options we're going
to specify the draggable elements as the
list items within that list the
draggable library is going to emit its
own custom events which we can intercept
here to emit our own custom event that
will have the newly sorted list again
there are multiple custom events that
you might need but the one that we care
about is sortable stop at that point we
know the user is done sorting the list
so we'll go ahead and take the initial
array reorder it and then you mitt that
out through our custom event emitter so
the parent component can listen to it
and handle it accordingly the sortable
stop event keeps track of all the
elements in the list and it will give us
the new index and the old index of the
item that was moved so we'll use this
method as just a context for mutating
the original data so what we can do here
is take the original data as our
starting point then we can splice off
the old index and then Reese Pleiss it
back into the new index once we have the
array in the format that we want we can
go ahead and omit it out as the value
from our custom event in the next step
we'll have the parent component listen
to this event and then update the
firestore database with the new value
now that we have our directive finished
we'll go into the HTML for the component
we can just insert it into an unordered
list and that will give us access to
both its input properties as well as its
output properties the data that we read
from the database will be an observable
so I'm doing an NG if statement here
with the document and setting that
document as a template variable then
we'll pass that to the data input on the
directive and then lastly we will listen
to our custom stop event and then we'll
write an event handler that will update
the database when that fire
now we can loop over the array of emojis
and render a list item for each one then
while working in HTML I want to add a
couple of extra things first I'll add
another button here that the user can
click to remove an item from an array
then I'll move outside of our loop and
add an additional method that we can use
to add an additional emoji to the array
and these are mostly just so I can show
you the new array methods and firestore
now we'll go into our component type
script and finish this feature out I am
importing an angular fire store and then
also fires store directly from the
firebase app namespace we can inject
angular fire store in the constructor
and then we'll set up one variable for
our document reference so we can make
updates on it and then another one for
the actual observable data then I'll go
ahead and define those during ng on an
it for now I'm just going to point to a
dummy document that I have saved in the
emojis collection then we can define our
observable of that document by calling
value changes on the reference here's
what that document actually looks like
in the database we have an array data
structure here called faves and it
currently has three different emojis in
it when the user sorts this list we can
update the array on fire store by simply
making a reference to the document and
calling update with the new array we set
up the event emitter in the directive to
send the newly sorted array so this is
all the code we need to update the
document on fire store but if you want
to add a single item to the array one
way to do that is with the new fire
store or a union method which will
ensure that a unique item is added to
the existing array this is really nice
when you want to enforce uniqueness in
the array which is exactly what we want
to do here so we'll call fire store
field value array Union and then pass in
the element that we want to add to it if
that value already exists in the array
then nothing will happen but otherwise
it will append that item to the end of
the array you can also remove items from
the array which is also very useful
because a lot of times you don't already
know the index of the item and you just
want it gone so fire store field value
array remove will find that element in
the array and remove it so that takes
care of all of our typescript code but
in order to make drag-and-drop look good
you're going to have to spend quite a
bit of time in your CSS styling one of
the cool things about draggable is that
it will add a whole bunch of different
CSS classes to your elements
depending on what state they're in
within the draggable list for example we
might want to add a style to the
container element when it's being
dragged like a blue border then the
source element that's being dragged we
might want to make that a lighter color
and scale it down a little bit then once
the items placed we'll go ahead and
color the background to green and
draggable will remove this class after a
second so we can get that green flashing
effect when the item is set and another
cool thing draggable does is that it
creates a mirror element of the item
that was selected so you can use that to
build adding more complex UI and to
handle things like animations when we go
to our demo you can see that a lot of
different classes are being swapped out
on the elements as we drag things around
here and as you can imagine doing this
kind of stuff reliably from scratch
takes a lot of time and effort so using
a library like draggable is just going
to make your life a lot easier I'm gonna
go ahead and wrap up the video there if
it helped you please like and subscribe
and if you want to take your development
to the next level consider becoming a
pro member at angular firebase comm to
get access to all kinds of advanced
exclusive content designed to help you
build and ship your app faster thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you soon